hey everybody Doug Walker here just
doing a few updates here real fast first
of all if you're watching this on
channel awesome calm you'll be wondering
where's the NC Christmas you know
Christmas was Monday that got in the way
of editing I want to be my family and
everything so it'll be a day late we're
still gonna run it on YouTube on
Wednesday and we'll put on a channel
awesome calm there as well but yeah
that's where that is so sorry holidays
um
second when you see it you might be
wondering why we're not doing an
announcement at the end for the theme
month next year usually we do a theme
month every January that's because we're
postponing it the main reason being
because understand your critics are
taking a little longer to make we got
yeah like clip those reviews and big
productions and stuff like that and the
themes seem to kind of pile up because
we kind of go from you know Halloween to
commercials to Christmas to a Star Wars
review to a January theme month it's
just one of those things where we felt
like it was kind of piling up and we
wanted a little bit more variety so
instead of having a January we're gonna
move it to March we're gonna have a
whole month again dedicated I'm still
sorry I know like a lot of you you know
look forward to that but we're still
gonna be doing nostalgic quick reviews
and we're gonna have just something
different you know it's one of those
things we just kind of got sick of doing
like all these themes back-to-back and
we want to make them big we want to make
them like you know good productions and
everything so we just kind of get
exhausted after a while and we did
charity stream this year too so we did
all sorts of stuff and just the idea of
going into another month you know
running forward it's like well we kind
of need to just do a couple normal
reviews too so I will tell you what it
is though the theme the theme month that
we're gonna do in March it's gonna be
the Disney live-action reboots have you
been keeping up with these there's some
bad ones man and even if you like some
of them there's stuff to talk about so
definitely gonna have a lot of fun with
that and finally I think if you did
watch our charity stream you
no we're gonna keep it up for a little
bit more you can go to the video and you
can donate as for st. Jude and you know
the this time of the year even though I
think when you see this will probably be
after the holidays there's definitely
still you know just so much giving and
so much that can be done and you know we
always associate Christmas with you know
giving to others it doesn't have to be
just Christmas it can be all year round
I think you know this is a good example
of that that even though Christmas has
passed there's still so much you can
give and so much you can do so we're
going to leave the video up for a little
bit more you just go to the charity
stream video there's a donation button
there and even if by the time you get to
it it's gone you know what just give
anyway give to st. you they do
incredible work and if you do research
on them it's just amazing the advances
they've made and just how many people
they've helped so definitely go check
that out
and yeah I think that's about it like I
said just want to give an update on a
few things and about the theme month in
the review being laid and of course the
charity just give what you can so that's
about it and hopefully I'll see you
later bye